[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24
más Romero sala en nuestra mesa Mara
bienvenida buena mañana de jueves y
vamos a irnos a Puerto Rico para esta
Crónica de salud por qué porque ahí se
declaró la emergencia de salud pública a
raíz del paso del huracán
un gusto estar aquí como siempre es una
declaración que llegó el martes por la
tarde y que ahora además se ha redoblado
con la declaración de desastre mayor de
la Casa Blanca escuchemos Cómo era esta
declaración
el secretario del departamento de salud
y servicios humanos Javier Becerra
declaró hoy una emergencia de salud
pública para el territorio
estadounidense de Puerto Rico a raíz del
impacto del huracán Fiona esta
declaración sigue la declaración de
desastre del presidente Byron y les da
beneficiarios de Medicare y medicate
mayor flexibilidad para cumplir con sus
necesidades de salud de emergencia
recordemos que Mary care medicate son un
programas para personas mayores o con
pocos recursos Pues que con esta mayor
flexibilidad van a poder responder más
rápido a las pues necesidades de
emergencia que tenían como decía ese
comunicado no y es que tres días después
del paso del huracán acciona todavía más
del 70% de la población de Puerto Rico
Estaba sin acceso a la electricidad más
del 40% Estaba sin acceso a agua potable
y esto Pues por supuesto tiene unos
impactos muy directos sobre la salud de
las personas primero sobre las
instalaciones por ejemplo como hospital
de servicios de salud que no pueden
atender como deberían a procedimientos
pues quirúrgicos necesiten de
Electricidad cualquier tipo de
procedimiento en general también
personas que requieran aparatos para sus
tratamientos crónicos y leer más lejos
la diálisis o máquinas de oxígeno
también se ven afectados esto sin hablar
de la dificultad logística que provocan
este tipo de desastres para llegar a
acceder a los servicios de salud para
llegar a los puntos donde las personas
pueden ser atendidas si tienen cualquier
tipo de problema derivado o no del
huracán de hecho se cree que este ha
sido la causa de muerte de una bebé de
cuatro meses en Puerto Rico que no pudo
acceder a los servicios de salud además
se registran siete más que se creen que
están directamente o indirectamente
relacionadas siete muertes más con el
huracán en total 8 decesos en lo que
vamos de días de Pues apenas una semana
que no ha pasado todavía y se prevé que
probablemente a medida que pase el
tiempo se van a ir contando más Mira
hasta dónde llegó el agua lo podemos ver
ahí hasta más arriba de la cabeza de la
señora pero más allá de las
consecuencias inmediatas Marc Qué
consecuencias a largo plazo tienen todos
estos desastres Sí pues
desafortunadamente lo por el ejemplo del
huracán María que ya pasó por Puerto
Rico y otras islas del Caribe en 2017
Entonces vamos a revisar las cifras de
un estudio publicado en journal Of The
American Medical asociation que compara
o compara un grupo de pacientes y sus
condiciones de salud en 2015 antes del
huracán Perdón en 2019 después del
huracán no con estos cuatro años de
diferencia vemos que por ejemplo cifras
como el sedentarismo es decir no hacer
deporte aumentar o en la prevalencia
pasó del 35 al 44%. lo mismo el exceso
de alcohol lo reportaron en antes del
huracán a María un 12% después un 17 y
luego pues condiciones de salud como la
hipertensión o como el colesterol alto
que también aumentaron
significativamente entre la población
antes y después es un estudio con una
serie de limitaciones del grupo de
pacientes no es el mismo que cogieron
antes y después entonces pues ahí hay
unas diferencias demográficas que
podrían explicar un poco este tipo de
problemas pero vaya vemos que son a
consecuencias que van mucho más allá del
momento inmediato del impacto el
desastre sino que empujan todavía más
hacia abajo poblaciones que ya sufren de
este tipo de enfermedades o de
condiciones que tienen altas
prevalencias que por ejemplo pues a raíz
del estrés social o vital que se acentúa
con este tipo de desastres naturales
pero también de nuevo a raíz de la falta
de acceso a la salud de falta Pues de
recursos económicos que permitan comer
bien que permitan tener tiempo de hacer
ejercicio que permitan tener espacio
mental incluso para cuidar de la propia
salud entonces todo esto lo vimos hace
pues a cinco años quién sabe cómo va a
seguir pasando en estas Islas que están
tan azotadas constantemente por este
tipo de Huracanes hablamos
y precisamente vamos a profundizar en
esto que hay de la Salud Mental en este
tipo de situaciones Sí pues es
importante hablar de esto porque es uno
de los de las condiciones más afectadas
de las que no siempre se tiene tan en
cuenta O al menos en la inmediatez del
momento a veces se pasa por alto no por
ejemplo también volviendo al huracán
María de 2017 las líneas de atención
psico en Puerto Rico reportó no solo
mucho más llamadas sino que las personas
que llamaban reportaron intentos de
suicidio este número de gente aumentó un
246% es decir más del doble más del
triple de hecho lo mismo sucedió con las
interacciones suicidas casi se
duplicaron Un aumento de 83% en las
personas que llamaban Pero bueno sabemos
que el suicidio no es el único indicador
que no siempre está relacionado con la
Salud Mental Aunque pues claramente es
una mala noticia que esto esté
sucediendo hay muchos más factores que
entran a jugar también cuando hablamos
de la Salud Mental la incertidumbre no
también la pérdida de comunidad ya sea
por la muerte de personas o por la
migración en los desplazamientos que
provocan este tipo de problemas en
muchísima gente muchísimos
puertorriqueños salieron de La Isla
después de pues del huracán María casos
de estrés postraumático también entre
los niños de ansiedad y depresión que si
no se tratan se cronifican y a pesar de
que haya bonitos ejemplos de resiliencia
eso no quita que después de este tipo de
eventos pues haya verdaderos problemas y
oleadas de problemas de Salud Mental
paso perspectivas que son son que estos
tipos de desastres naturales ocurren
cada vez como a frecuencia había el
cambio al cambio climático a la crisis
climática mar claro exacto no unos
ejemplos son estos huracanes que estamos
hablando que apenas en Puerto Rico
todavía no había terminado de
recuperarse del huracán María Ya volvió
a sufrir otro huracán como loro campeona
sin quitar algunos que entre medio y
también llegaron a la isla esto sigue
pasando no iba a seguir intensificandose
además las zonas que más afectadas se
ven por este tipo de desastres son
precisamente las zonas que menos
responsabilidad tienen a la hora de
haber pues provocado no causado el
cambio climático y también son las que
menos recursos tienen tanto para hacerle
frente a los desastres como también a
estas consecuencias a largo plazo y para
terminar recordar que esa es una de las
reivindicaciones de muchos
puertorriqueños que sienten este trato
desigual por ejemplo con el territorio
continental estadounidense y que muchas
veces por ejemplo que un huracán María y
ahora también se han sentido bien
desamparados no frente frente a estos
desastres por la administración Federal
como siempre Gracias mañana con masa
salud en directo América de Frankfurt